il y à un peu plus d'une heure le
représentant du chancelier willy brandt
monsieur mba et le secrétaire d'état est
allemand helmut kohl ont signé à berlin
est le traité qui règle les rapports
entre les deux allemagnes la signature
de ce traité c'est la fin de 27 années
de guerre froide entre les deux
allemagnes il existe désormais deux
états allemands la république
démocratique allemande et la république
fédérale allemande qui pour commencer
vont échanger non pas des ambassadeurs
mais des représentants permanents et qui
seront admises toutes les deux ensemble
à l'onu l'année prochaine mais ce traité
signé ce matin n'a pas que des
conséquences diplomatiques
il a aussi des conséquences humaines et
c'est à cet aspect de la signature du
traité que cette particulièrement
intéressé
michel meyer
dans ces régions rurales est
relativement pauvre de la frontière l'on
s'était donc résignés à vivre avec le
mur et à ne pas revoir parents et amis
se trouvant de l'autre côté depuis plus
de 20 ans on attendait le dégel avec le
traité fondamental l'espoir renaît
tellement fragile que les habitants des
villages refuse encore de livrer leurs
craintes ou leur espoir devant une
caméra pourtant avec la signature du
traité les frontières s'ouvriront 30
fois par an dans le sens république
fédérale république démocratique mais
seulement pour les ressortissants des
régions frontalières les fiancés les
époux pourront se retrouver les
contrôles aux frontières devraient
s'humaniser
autre conséquence des nouvelles
relations entre les deux allemagnes
l'arrivée par petits groupes comme ici
dans la nuit froide de la basse-saxe de
quelques milliers de détenus d'allemagne
de l'est au départ 32000 condamnés ont
été admis suite aux accords qui ont
précédé le traité poursuivi pour délit
politique et de droit commun trois mille
d'entre eux ont souhaité est passé en
allemagne de l'ouest ou aux termes des
lois en vigueur la plupart des
prisonniers ne seront plus inquiétés
parmi ces amnistié venant de karl marx
stadt autrement dit chemnitz énormément
de jeunes de 20 et 30 ans qui à la
frontière pour manifester leur joie
nous sommes heureux c'est le plus beau
jour de noël le plus beau jour de ma vie
cet après midi nous étions encore en
prison disait-il certains étaient en
prison pour plus de 3 et 4 ans
c'est donc en de guy scène que se fait
la prise en charge de l'orientation
sociale délibéré qui sont envoyés dans
toutes les régions de la république
fédérale pour la plupart d'entre eux une
période de réadaptation commence
normale trois ans d'après vu sa fiancée
depuis quatre ans il désespère de la
revoir un jour malgré le traité en cela
il est peut être trop pessimiste